[Music]
>> Hello.
My name is Gang Hua.
I'm a computer vision researcher
in the Intelligent Input Group.
Today I'm going to introduce
three pieces of work here which
will enable any users to render
artistic style visual artifacts
and good looking for both images
and videos.
So the first piece of work we're
going to present is called Style
Bank, which is -- what happened?
Which is summarized in a paper
we published in CVPR this year.
In this piece of work, we
propose an explicit
representation of visual styles
as a set of convolutional
filters and decompose the image
space.
Because of this explicit
representation, we can do faster
rendering and faster incremental
linear of different styles.
Here I show you some results
here.
As you can see, we can render
the styles in a pretty
consistent way for a large
variety of different visual
styles.
So several advantages here is
that like it enables faster
training of new styles.
For example, if we want to -- we
can -- fix most of the
parameters fixed, and we only
need to use, like, eight minutes
to train a new model, versus
existing work usually is, like,
several hours.
The second thing is that we can
quickly render new styles by
holding the intermediate
representation fixed and which
has little swap to different
filters.
And also we can easily do linear
fusion of different styles by
linear combination of the
filters.
What is even more important, we
can do region-specific style
fusion.
For example, we can render
different regions of the image
with different visual styles.
As you can see, this is our
filter results with different
styles.
So next I'm going to show -- we
can apply the techniques to
videos, like, as you can
imagine, like when you render
the results frame to frame, it
is going to have a lot of
shimmering.
So in this work we propose an
algorithm which can leverage the
consistency across frames.
Like, we can generate much more
stable video results.
You can see the difference.
So in the second piece of work,
we are going to show black trick
where we can swap the style of
two images.
Traditionally, image analysis
work, like you have three input
and one output.
Here we try to generate two
outputs from a pair of inputs.
So in our method we take a very
complicated approach where we
run the images through deep
networks, and we do patch
matching and swapping to
correspondence and do some
multi-resolution reconstruction.
As a result, we dynamically show
you that we can actually deform
and just render the two images
in different styles.
Here I'm going to present a
little bit more results here.
As you can see, we can sort of
render the source image into
different outputs based on the
reference.
Here are some poor results we
compare with existing offering,
like our results are always more
consistent and visually more
pleasant, especially for
portrait photos.
And here we can even render the
input source file to like a
sketched face to a real face.
And here are some more examples.
And you can also do facial
makeup transfer.
If a face looks good, you can
try to mimic the same kind of
visual makeup.
And here are more on faces.  We
render the same face into
different styles, like the Mona
Lisa looking and a bunch of
other artistic styles.
So actually the first piece of
technology, indeed, that's been
transferred into Microsoft Pix,
which is the AI camera produced
from our group and the rest of
the technology are under
transferring to different
Microsoft products.
Perhaps you will see it in some
of those offerings.
Thank you.